mon Parin qui s'est fait agresser il a
eu des fractures au crâne et des peres
de mémoire c'était il y a un an quand
même mais ça m'a encore beaucoup
[Musique]
marqué on entend beaucoup plus parler
ben dans la vie de tous les jours les
jeunes de nos jours en fait deviennent
de plus en plus violents dès le plus
jeune âge en grandissant
on on a besoin de se sentir en sécurité
pour
sortir
oui bah par exemple si je sors le soir
au centre-ville ou dans certains
quartiers je pense que j'irai plus avec
une amie avec de la famille mais toute
seule j'irai pas je dois pas être
inconsciente et me dire qu'il se passera
jamais rien parce que ça peut arriver
mais je veux pas non plus me dire dois
m'empêcher de faire des choses dans ma
vie
justement je m'informe un peu et puis
j'essaie d'être un peu plus
prudente dans une ville il y a une
application qui permet de faire des
itinéraires sûr on pourrait interdire
certains jeux vidéos qui sont trop
violents pour les jeunes faut vraiment
pas s'empêcher de vivre sa vie pour ça
parce que tant que ça nous est pas
arrivé à nous faut pas faut en être
conscient mais faut pas s'empêcher de
vivre